this is an abortion rights demonstration
in 1972
people marched to demand the right to
legal abortions
and the next year the supreme court case
roe v wade granted them that right
but fast forward to almost 50 years and
protests for abortion rights are still
happening
a lot of the fight over abortion policy
centers on restrictive laws set by state
governments and the courts that uphold
or strike down those laws
including the supreme court but the
president and congress hold a unique
power over abortion access
because they have the final say on the
federal dollars that support it
in every federal budget for the past 43
years among all the programs the
government funds like the military
foreign aid and education
there's also language about something
the government can't spend federal money
on
coverage of abortion except in the case
of rape or incest or if the pregnancy
would place the woman
in danger of death this provision is
called the hyde amendment
and it disproportionately affects
low-income people who rely on federally
funded health care
every president since 1976 has supported
the hyde amendment by approving an
annual federal budget from congress
that's included it
but the 2020 election could change this
because while one candidate supports the
hyde amendment
the other has vowed to oppose it
[Music]
the height amendment's induction into
the federal budget can be traced back to
roe v
wade in the years immediately following
this decision the federal government
paid for abortions through medicaid
which accounted for roughly a third of
all abortion procedures
but the anti-abortion backlash was swift
including in congress
in 1976 illinois representative henry
hyde proposed the abortion-restricting
hyde amendment during an annual budget
hearing
it passed with a 199-165 vote ending up
in that year's spending bill where it
has stayed
ever since voted for by anti-abortion
politicians
and pro-abortion rights politicians in
every case
these budgets have been approved and
signed by the sitting president
in 1977 henry hyde made the intentions
of his amendment
clear he said i certainly would like to
prevent if i could legally
anybody having an abortion a rich woman
a middle-class woman or a poor woman
unfortunately the only vehicle available
is the medicaid bill
there's a handful of agencies directly
affected by the hyde amendment that
provide health care through federal
funding
like the indian health service and the
peace corps but medicaid is the biggest
it pays for basic health services for
just over 76 million people in the us
who live near the poverty line or are
disabled
part of medicaid's funding comes from
federal dollars the other part comes
from the state you live in
abortion care in the united states is
largely driven by where you live
both in terms of the availability of
services
and in addition to that the ability of
insurance to pay for it
these 16 states will help medicaid users
cover the cost of abortion
but these 34 states and washington dc
won't anyone seeking an abortion there
has to pay the full bill
that means nearly 8 million people of
child bearing age who live in these
states
aren't covered for abortion services
because of the hyde amendment
these medicaid restrictions place the
biggest burden on low-income people
we could basically quit doing the work
we do
if the hyde amendment didn't exist lori
roberts manages an abortion fund in
alabama
one of the most restrictive states when
it comes to abortion access
the abortion fund is a organization that
helps people access abortion care it can
be anything that removes the barriers to
getting
to and from the clinic and then there's
just direct financial support
for the abortion procedure the price of
an abortion in the first 10 weeks of
pregnancy without coverage is roughly
500
and it gets more expensive in later
weeks of pregnancy
that's a lot of money for someone who
qualifies for medicaid to be eligible
you generally have to make less than 138
of the federal poverty line for a single
person that's
less than an 18 000 annual income for a
family of two
it's 24 000 and for a family of three
it's about thirty thousand dollars
because of racial disparities in our
country
medicaid recipients are more likely to
be black or hispanic
i can personally say what it was like
for me right i went to the clinic i went
for my first appointment
i scheduled my procedure i wanted to i
wanted to have a procedure
and i couldn't i didn't have the money
in time
that doesn't mean that i don't love my
child it doesn't mean any of those
things
but what it means is that i went through
a lot of emotional and physical trauma
because what should have been a decision
that was only mine was taken away from
me
a study of 269 women from 2015 to 2017
in louisiana a state that doesn't cover
abortion through medicaid
shows that 29 of women would have had an
abortion had medicaid covered it
which is the intended effect for
anti-abortion advocates
fewer people having abortions
abortion restrictions like the hyde
amendment have made their way into other
types of health insurance coverage too
in 2010 congress didn't pass the
affordable care act until included
language saying marketplace plans don't
have to cover abortion
today these states won't cover it under
marketplace plans
and these states even restrict private
insurance companies from covering the
procedure
and so that more and more people are
affected and they may not even know that
they've been affected
until they seek abortion care but it's
the medicaid restrictions both federal
and state that specifically target poor
people
abortion is like many other services if
you have means
you can either have insurance that pays
for a service or you can
afford to pay for these services out of
pocket and if it's not offered in a
place that's close to you you can afford
to either
travel get lodging
take time off of work get child care all
of those things are things that are
available to higher income
women that may not be available to lower
income women
the two candidates in the 2020 election
are solidly in their partisan corners on
the issue of abortion access
but that wasn't always the case joe
biden took office in the senate in 1973
the same year roe v wade passed and he
supported the hyde amendment since it
entered the federal spending bill in
1976
but in 2020 this is the landscape the
state you live in and how much money you
have
are the biggest factors in whether
someone can access an abortion
which is why joe biden as a presidential
candidate says he's changed his stance
if i believe health care is a right as i
do i can no longer support an amendment
that makes that right dependent on
someone's zip code
and trump has only dug deeper in his
anti-abortion position
i notified congress that i would veto
any legislation
that weakens pro-life policies or that
encourages
the destruction of human life
it's also why the stakes for abortion
policy for the 2020 election
are clear it's a choice between a
president who plans to lift this barrier
to abortion access for the country's
most vulnerable people
and one who will keep the status quo at
their expense
[Music]
thanks for watching this episode of our
2020 election series
for this series we asked you our
audience what election coverage we
should focus on
and we made this video because a lot of
you asked what this election means for
abortion policy in the country
vivian asked us to talk about women's
right to choose
and maintaining abortion rights matthew
asks
how will access to abortion and
reproductive health services be affected
by the outcome of the 2020 election
and ami asked about reproductive rights
the ability to access birth control safe
abortions and sex education
we want to know what you think the
candidates should be talking about
tell us at vox.com election videos
[Music]